for more on the search we're joined by
rear Admiral John mauger of the U.S
Coast Guard Admiral mugger thank you so
much for taking the time this morning
you know I went to bed thinking about
this story woke up thinking about the
story hoping that there would be some
news it seems like we have news how
optimistic how encouraged should we be
by this turn of events that they are
that they've heard some kind of noise
down there
yeah well uh thank you for having us on
this morning this continues to be a
really complex case with both a surface
search and a subsea search and our
thoughts are with both the crew members
and the families I know that this is an
incredibly difficult time for the family
and so we're working very hard as part
of an international effort as part of a
unified command with the U.S Navy with
the Canadian Armed Forces Canadian Coast
Guard and private Enterprise to bring as
many assets to bear as many capabilities
to bear at the search site to conduct
both a thorough air surface and subsea
surface surge yeah we know we know you
guys have all the best people in the
business working on this 24 7. do you
remain optimistic at this point we know
that the the hours left of oxygen that
they have is getting very very very very
close to
expiring if if there's a way to say that
this yeah this is an incredibly uh
complex case and uh so we're really
focused on on bringing all those
capabilities that mayor uh as mentioned
in the brief we had a P3 uh aircraft
Aurora aircraft flying yesterday that
had Sona buoys the Sona boys detected
noise uh in the water uh we don't know
uh the source of that noise but we've
shared that information with navy
experts to classify it in the meantime
what we've done is reprioritize the two
remote operated vehicles that we have uh
searching in the water and the one
surface vessel that has a sonar
capability at the surface of the water
in the area those noises to see if we
can locate uh the source of those noises
and and locate the people on the
smartphone well Admiral how how common
is it to pick up noises is the ocean a
noisy place because a regular person
hears of these noises and thinks well
it's got to be yes it's got to be them
it's got to be them I mean How likely is
it in your experience that this is a
human cause noise
so this is an incredibly complex uh site
there you have to remember that it's the
the wreck site of the Titanic so there
is a lot of uh metal and and different
uh objects in the water around the site
uh that's why it's so important that
we've engaged uh experts from the Navy
that understands uh the science behind
noise and and can classify or or give us
better information about what the source
of that noise may be in the meantime
it's something it's a Target it's a
focus for us to look at and so we've
deployed the remote operated vehicles
and the surface vessel uh the Canadian
Coast Guard surface vessel that has
sonar capability in the vicinity of that
to to see if we can detect anything in
the water in that area
Admiral we have to get going but just
quickly
um how long will you hold on to hope for
before you start planning for the worst
and so as long as there's a opportunity
for survival we will continue to work
with this broad unified command to bring
every resource to impair on on the
search over the course of the next 24
hours we're going to bring additional
vessels additional remote operated uh
vehicles and we're going to continue to
fly in the air so we'll continue to look
and we'll continue to hold out hope as
well Admiral mugger thank you